[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend im norden in den
bundesländern schleswig-holstein und
mecklenburg-vorpommern hat heute die
schule wieder begonnen und mit den
urlaubern zurück kommt auch das krone
thema wie werden die meist ungeimpften
schülerinnen und schüler geschützt
welche quarantäne beziehungsweise
isolations regeln gelten wenn es in der
schule positive fälle gibt
letztlich geht es um die frage nach der
pandemischen lernkurve sind wir aus den
erfahrungen des letzten herbstes
schlauer geworden oder gibt es wieder
chaos wird delta durch die schulen
rauschen oder lässt sich das verhindern
vor allem lässt sich verhindern dass es
wieder schulschließungen gibt zeit genug
um sich vorzubereiten gab es das sich
mit der delta variante eine vierte welle
aufbaut ist auch längst bekannt man darf
also gespannt sein
hannah hebestreit berichtet aus kiel für
gut 300 kinder der gerhart hauptmann
grundschule in kiel ellerbek geht das
große lernen wieder los sie kommen aus
den ferien mit blumen für die
lehrerinnen und nachweisen dass sie frei
sind von corona weil sich in kiel immer
mehr menschen anstecken
verteidigen sie ihre schule gegen das
virus schon an der pforte
wir wollen die schule nicht wieder zu
machen und wir wollen auch keine klassen
in quarantäne haben wir werden sehr sehr
sehr sorgfältig arbeiten um rechtzeitig
zu testen um sehr genau zu testen
und so beginnt das neue schuljahr fast
so wie das alte aufgehört hat regelmäßig
müssen sie lüften und dem unterricht
lernen sie immer noch mit masken
weil ich finde was nicht einfach unser
teil und aber das ist einfach okay weil
ich nicht daran schon gewöhnt ich habe
mich daran gewöhnt und aber mein
schützling damit gewöhnt haben sie sich
in der klasse 3d auch an die korona
tests zweimal die woche heißt es
stäbchen in die nase klassenlehrerin
anja gießener dirigiert die
probenentnahme nach sechs wochen ferien
immer noch mit großer routine noch ein
paar minuten dann weiß sie ob sie mit
dem unterricht loslegen kann
oder beim gesundheitsamt anrufen sollte
viele lehrer staaten trotz all dieser
maßnahmen mit einem mulmigen gefühl ins
neue schuljahr sie fühlen sich nicht gut
vorbereitet weil es an personal fehlt
sie fühlen sich nicht gut vorbereitet
weil die technische ausstattung immer
noch nicht gut ist und sich fühlen sich
auch nicht gut vorbereitet weil es
keinen sozusagen notfallplan für
mögliche verschlechterungen gibt damit
corona den bildungsbetrieb nicht noch
einmal erheblich beeinträchtigt setzen
auch kiels bildungsministerium bremen
auf eine impfkampagne für schüler mobile
luftfilter sind im norden dagegen
umstritten
wir haben uns zum beispiel über nacht
hat laufen lassen dann ist am nächsten
morgen so gut wie keinen alkohol mehr zu
finden aber unter laufenden betrieb gibt
es entsprechende untersuchungen dass
dadurch die konzentration des alkohols
vielleicht um 50 prozent gesenkt werden
kann
drastischere auswirkungen sind dann
nicht zu erwarten
unabhängig davon schleswig holstein die
kinder im neuen schuljahr nicht noch
einmal aus den klassenzimmern verbannen
alle unsere pläne sehen auch genau das
vor keinen distanz lernen mehr sondern
hygieneregeln die kann auch mal
verschärft werden aber alles im
präsenzunterricht in unseren schulen
das klingt sehr absolut also keine
hintertür ist bleibt dabei genau
und so werden sie in der 3d auch im
winter die fenster immer wieder öffnen
und sich regelmäßig testen
ein steht wohl fest je mehr erwachsenen
geimpft sind desto geringer sind die
risiken wenn kinder das virus aus der
schule nach hause tragen und umgekehrt
nur geht diese rechnung nicht auf weil
die impfquote bislang nicht hoch genug
ist für das impfen bei den erwachsenen
zu werben vor allem auch bei den jungen
erwachsenen im party freudigen alter ist
eine maßnahme doch die politik verlässt
sich nicht allein darauf sondern erhöht
jetzt auch den druck die unter 17
jährigen zu hilfe
die gesundheitsminister der länder haben
sich nach ihrer konferenz heute dazu
eindeutig positioniert das problem dabei
ist dass die ständige impfkommission
dafür noch keine ausdrückliche
empfehlung ausgesprochen hat und so
entsteht ein konflikt der bei eltern
womöglich noch mehr verunsicherung
ausgelöst
dazu gleich ein gespräch doch zunächst
berichtet britta spiekermann
masken und tests alles wie gehabt nach
anderthalb jahren pandemie landes
chefinnen und chefs stellen sich jetzt
die zukunft anderswo
plötzlich soll es im angebot an schulen
geben zum beispiel in schleswig holstein
und mecklenburg vorpommern schon in zwei
wochen
niemand übt druck auf die impfung von
kindern und jugendlichen ist allein
entscheidung der eltern gemeinsam mit
ihren kindern und das wird auch so
bleiben
bund und länder sind sich heute abend
ungewohnt einig und wärmen einen alten
beschluss neu auf es soll tempo gemacht
werden wegen der sogenannten
herdenimmunität was das thema der kinder
und jugend impfungen angeht haben wir
einen einstimmigen beschluss gefasst
dass wir dieses impfangebot jetzt in
allen ländern unterbreiten wollen wir
sind damit den beschluss gefolgt den wir
bereits am 6 mai gefasst haben wo wir
damals schon gesagt haben wir wollen ein
impf angebot unterbreiten
damals war auch noch wenig impfstoff da
jetzt ist ausreichend impfstoff zur
verfügung
in schulen in sachsen in zentren soll
kindern und jugendlichen an impfangebot
bis ende august 2021 gemacht werden
ärztliche aufklärung inklusive
zustimmung der eltern voraussetzungen
zunehmend in einer außenseiterposition
thomas mertens chef der stiko ein mann
der vorsicht er ist der vorsitzende der
unabhängigen expertenkommission die
maßgeblich ist für impfempfehlungen es
gebe noch zu wenig daten über mögliche
folgeschäden so seine warnung heute die
entscheidung an ihm vorbei für den
weiteren verlauf der pandemie in
deutschland wäre es absolut erforderlich
dass sich die 18 bis 59 jährigen
vollständig mit dem reichlich
verfügbaren impfstoff impfen lassen
die kinder spielen für die epidemiologie
in deutschland und für den verlauf der
pandemie eine ausgesprochen
untergeordnete rolle
ich halte den druck den die politik
ausübt eigentlich für wenig der druck
der politik mertens main vor allem den
bundesgesundheits
spahn drängt seit langem auf eine
allgemeine empfehlung für kinder und
jugendliche am abend begrüßt sparen die
entscheidung nur kurz und schriftlich
jetzt ist schon von einer entmachtung
der stiko die rede einer frau ist in
jedem fall
und noch einen beschluss gibt es heute
ab september soll es corona
auffrischungsimpfungen geben vor allem
in pflegeeinrichtungen und für kranke
menschen in diesem punkt sind sie stiko
bund und länder einig als fazit könnte
man aber heute durchaus von einem riss
sprechen zwischen politik und experten
kommission und der vorsitzende der
heutigen minister rundes bayerns
gesundheitsminister klaus holetschek
guten abend gut' morgenpost die stiko
die ständige impfkommission die würde
gerne noch etwas warten um eine bessere
datenlage zu haben warum hat die politik
ist jetzt so eilig mit dem impfen von
kindern und jugendlichen
na ja wir haben eigentlich nichts neues
beschlossen als das was wir im mai
tatsächlich schon eigentlich vollzogen
haben dass wir in ins angebot machen
unter der voraussetzung dass eine
ärztliche aufklärung stattfindet dass
die sorgeberechtigten zustimmen und eine
gewisse risikoabschätzung da ist da hat
die stiko auch gesagt dass das möglich
ist insofern ist es nichts neues aber
sie beginnen ja jetzt eine art kampagne
sie haben ja sich heute dafür auch extra
getroffen um darüber zu sprechen wie man
das info angebot für kinder und
jugendliche breiter aufstellt sein sonst
hätten sich ja das treffen heute
eigentlich sparen können wenn es nichts
neues gibt
na ja wir haben ja jetzt schon 20
prozent dieser altersgruppe die einmal
erst geimpft ist und wir wollten jetzt
noch mal gemeinsam auch bestätigen dass
es wichtig ist dieses impfangebot in
allen ländern zu machen in vielen hat es
schon stattgefunden und das war das sind
es heute auch noch mal sehr deutlich zu
diskutieren auch mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister gibt es da ja
durchaus auch deutliche kritik aus der
politik an der stiko dass die anders
entscheidet als das beispiel
entsprechende kommissionen und behörden
in anderen ländern tun
der spd gesundheitsexperte lauterbach
spricht sogar von einer
außenseiterposition die deutsche stieg
oder einnehmen würde sehen sie das
ähnlich kritisch wenn sie sich wünschen
dass dann da doch jetzt schneller eine
empfehlung käme um die eltern auch zu
beruhigen ich glaube dass es für die
stiko da nicht einfach ist die stiko
zieht den individuellen fall wir müssen
in der pandemie natürlich noch mehr
sehen und ich denke das was wir
schon von den ländern ist einfach ein
angebot zu unterbreiten wo der arzt auch
noch mal eine wichtige rolle spielt
insofern glaube ich sind wir jetzt gut
unterwegs und ich habe ja heute auch
wahrgenommen dass die stiko glaube ich
die nächsten ein zwei wochen doch zu
einer entscheidung kommen wird
die aber auch durchaus so ausfallen
könnte das hier keine empfehlung
aussprechen es durchaus möglich deswegen
ist die stiko ein unabhängiges gremium
aber sie schließt ja nicht aus dass die
möglichkeit der impfung trotzdem gegeben
ist und das haben wir heute noch einmal
deutlich gemacht und wollen das mit
niedrigschwelligen angeboten auch
untermauern
sie sprachen karten ganz wichtigen punkt
an als sie sagten die stiko weg nach
anderen kriterien womöglich ab nämlich
nach individuelle nutzen risiko und die
politik sieht er das epidemiologische
gesamtgeschehen also richtung
herdenimmunität wenn da überhaupt
irgendwas sind die richtung möglich sein
soll dann müssen auch die kinder waren
ich denke das individuelle risiko ist
ganz wichtig und wesentlich das darf man
nicht ausblenden aber ich glaube wenn
die möglichkeit eröffnet ist auch von
der stiko dass sie sagt unter den
bestimmten parametern ist ein solches
impfangebot okay dann sollten wir das
auch nutzen in dieser zeit dass auch zu
machen zumal ja jetzt zwei impfstoffe da
sind die auch zugelassen sind
das war im mai vergangenen jahres noch
anders und da war auch noch weniger
impfstoff da deswegen mussten wir dann
erst auch in die wohlhabenden gruppen
nochmal ringe steckt sagt aber auch
dieser zulassungsstudie die es ihnen zu
wenig das sind zu wenig kinder die daran
teilgenommen haben ja die stiko hat
einen bestimmten klick auf das thema das
ist ja auch okay aber wie gesagt sie
schließt die möglichkeit nicht aus und
deswegen denke ich ist es gut und
richtig wenn wir jetzt von dieser
möglichkeit gebrauch machen und ein
angebot unterbreiten ein angebot ist ja
keine verpflichtung sondern ist eine
option das anzunehmen ich habe in vielen
impfzentren jetzt schon auch junge
menschen getroffen die gesagt ja mir ist
es ganz wichtig dass ich mich jetzt
impfen lassen kann
und denen sollte man das auch möglich
machen wer es nicht vor allem wichtig
jetzt auch zum beispiel an die jungen
erwachsenen heranzugehen da gibt es
diese diskussionen über soll man impfen
oder nicht ja er auf der
medizinisch-wissenschaftlichen seite
eigentlich nicht und das sind die die
jetzt auch viele kontakte haben die
lange eingesperrt waren jetzt auch erst
recht partys feiern was ihnen auch jeder
von herzen gönnen
aber wer nicht diese gruppe über 17 18
20 jährige die studenten
wenn die nicht jetzt eigentlich
wichtiger als zu sagen müssen jetzt
unbedingt 12 13 14 jährige impfen und
geben begeben uns in einem konflikt mit
der stiko dann auch misstrauen weckt
also das tun wir auch ich glaube wir
haben jetzt viele aktionen draußen auch
für studentinnen und studenten auch für
junge erwachsene wo wir noch mal
wirklich werben und um bitten dass man
sich impfen lässt weil impfen der weg
aus der pandemie heraus ist das eine
schliesst das andere tatsächlich nicht
aus und den konflikt mit der stiko kann
ich an der stelle nicht erkennen weil
wir ja einen weg gehen die die stiko
durchaus für möglich hält und auf dieser
basis unterbreiten wir jetzt dieses
impfangebot manche eltern haben
vielleicht auch das gefühl naja ihr
kriegt die schulen nicht sicher genug
gemacht keine luftfilter und ähnliches
dann müssen jetzt halt die kinder
geimpft werden weil es da versäumnisse
geld ich glaube bei den schulen ist es
impfen ja nicht das einzige thema es
kann ein baustein sein wir müssen dort
sehr stark auf testungen setzen auf das
thema maske auf lüfter auch auf
reinigungsgeräte für die luft das tun
wir auch mit verschiedenen
förderprogrammen des bundes aber
natürlich auch des landes wie in bayern
zum beispiel der tag danke für das
interview gerne das gespräch haben wir
aufgezeichnet nachher im heute-journal
update gibt es zu dem thema dann noch
ein interview mit dem
fdp-gesundheitspolitiker android mann
der zugleich professor für infektiologie
ist und an kritiker der heutigen
beschlüsse in den hochwassergebieten
steht neben den aufräumarbeiten und der
bewältigung des ganzen horrors denn mit
dieser katastrophe einher geht weiter
eine brennende frage im raum warum boden
so viele menschen nicht rechtzeitig
gewarnt und aus ihren häusern geholt mit
dem thema geht es jetzt bei heinz wolf
weiter die staatsanwaltschaft koblenz
teilte heute mit sie prüfe nach der
unwetterkatastrophe im aartal die
einleitung eines ermittlungsverfahrens
wegen des anfangsverdachts der
fahrlässigen tötung und körperverletzung
in folge möglicherweise unterlassener
oder verspäteter warnungen oder
evakuierungen
durch das hochwasser sind in rheinland
pfalz mindestens 138 menschen ums leben
gekommen
besonders schwer betroffen ist der kreis
ahrweiler
in zahlreichen orten sind infrastruktur
und häuser vollständig zerstört das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe hat ein
spendenkonto für die vom hochwasser
betroffenen regionen eingerichtet die
iban lautet de 65 104 106 100 104 106
100 stichwort zdf hochwasser weitere
informationen finden sie unter spenden
punkt zdf de und initiativtext auf seite
8 190
seit tagen schon wütend in zahlreichen
urlaubsregionen am mittelmeer
verheerende waldbrände
besonders kritisch ist die lage in der
türkei dort sind bereits acht menschen
ums leben gekommen
teilweise mussten menschen mit booten in
sicherheit gebracht werden
und starke winde lassen brandherde immer
wieder neu entfachen
italien hat landesweit mehr als 800
waldbrände gemeldet und europäische
hilfe angefordert
besonders betroffen sind sizilien
sardinien und das umland von pescara an
der adria die menschen kämpfen auch in
griechenland gegen viele feuer rhodos
und der peloponnes sind betroffen
dazu kommt eine extreme trockenheit und
eine hitzewelle mit temperaturen bis zu
45 grad
mit mehreren veranstaltungen ist heute
an die im nationalsozialismus ermordeten
sinti und roma erinnert worden
so auch mit einer kranzniederlegung zum
heutigen europäischen gedenkt tag für
sinti und roma im beisein des
zentralratsvorsitzenden rose
mit dem 2 august wird an die ermordung
der etwa 4300 bis zu diesem tag 1944
noch im ns-vernichtungslager
auschwitz-birkenau verbliebenen sinti
und roma erinnert
die belarussische olympia sprinterin
christina tiemann auf sky hat von der
polnischen botschaft in tokio ein
humanitäres visum erhalten
die 24 jährige hatte zuvor erklärt sie
habe nach öffentlicher kritik an
belarussischen sportfunktionären gegen
ihren willen aus japan ausgeflogen
werden sollen
mehr dazu und zu den sportlichen
höhepunkten bei den olympischen spielen
am ende dieser sendung oder in der zdf
mediathek wegen vermehrter illegale
grenzübertritte von belarus in das
eu-land litauen erhebt die europäische
kommission schwere vorwürfe gegen die
belarussische regierung
präsident lukaschenko hatte in der
vergangenheit offen damit gedroht als
reaktion auf eu sanktionen
migranten etwa aus dem nahen osten oder
afrika nach litauen passieren zu lassen
eu innenkommissarin johansson besuchte
heute unter anderem einen grenzübergang
und ein aufnahme camp im südosten von
litauen in der hauptstadt vilnius sagte
sie am rande von gesprächen mit dem
litauischen präsidentin mehr
unterstützung beim grenzschutz zu im
umgang mit diktaturen werden sich die
europäer in den nächsten jahren noch
warm anziehen müssen
belarus ist da nur ein kleiner player
die wirklich großen sind natürlich
russland und china
vor allem china die deutsche politik
gegenüber peking ist bislang ein
ständiger spagat zwischen politischer
einerseits und andererseits enormen
wirtschaftsinteressen und dem bedarf
nach zusammenarbeit weil klimaschutz und
anderen themen
der globale machtanspruch der chinesin
ist allerdings so groß geworden und den
westlichen verbündeten ein solcher dorn
im auge dass nun auch die bundeswehr
flagge zeigt heute startete die fregatte
bayern eine siebenmonatige reise durch
die weltmeere
hauptziel ist der indopazifik der vor
allem im südchinesischen meer eine menge
konfliktzonen bietet andreas künast
hintergründen es ist ein sehr
bundesdeutscher abschied im
marinestützpunkt wilhelmshaven zu einer
sehr bundesdeutschen mission vor den
rund 200 soldaten der fregatte bayern
liegen fast sieben monate fast ein
dutzend hafenstädte und ein fast
lösbarer auftrag das 127 jahre altes
kriegsschiff china ein bisschen
abschrecken aber bloß nicht verärgern
soll ist das bundesdeutsche daran von
wilhelmshaven nimmt die fregatte bayern
zunächst kurs auf das mittelmeer wo die
nato mit der operation sie guardian
terrorismus verhindern soll dann durch
das rote meer zur eu mission atalanta
auftrag die seefahrt vor piraten
schützen dann weiter durch den pazifik
bis unter anderem japan südkorea und
schließlich in die politischen und
tiefen vor der küste chinas
nein es ist kein zeichen gegen
irgendjemand es ist wirklich ein zeichen
für die regelbasierte ordnung für die
freiheit für die freiheit von
schifffahrt von der wir als exportnation
abhängig sind und auch profitieren
und ja es ist ein zeichen auch an die
verbündeten auch an die like meinte
staaten im indopazifischen raum von den
laien minded von den gleichgesinnten
staaten sind es vor allem die usa die
versuchen gegen den wachsenden
machtanspruch chinas eine allianz der
demokraten zu schmieden aber es gibt
eine bremserin die bundesregierung noch
ist man in deutschland etwas zögerlich
was sagen den schulterschluss mit den
usa angeht mit den mit blick auf die
chinapolitik man ist eher skeptisch
darüber wie der präsident momentan noch
die die chinapolitik handhabt auch
deutschland beunruhigt wie china im
südchinesischen meer anspruch erhebt auf
zahlreiche gebiete anderer staaten wie
aus riffen und sandbänken erst
künstliche inseln werden und dann
chinesische militär basen aber die
antwort ist unentschieden und sehr
bundesdeutsche die fregatte bayern die
china kein bisschen verärgert aber ein
klein bisschen warnen soll
china warnt ein bisschen zurück
das kriegsschiff des betreffenden landes
sollte im südchinesischen meer alles
unterlassen was den frieden und die
stabilität in der region untergräbt das
eine deutsche fregatte flagge zeigt im
indopazifik erstmals seit 20 jahren hält
ein teil der opposition für einen fehler
was wurde man in berlin das wurde man
paris sagen wenn die chinesischen flotte
im ärmelkanal aufschlagen wurde und
behaupten würde sie würde den raum dort
ärmelkanals schützen ich glaube es wurde
sehr starke widerstände dagegen geben
die chinesische marine hat immer wieder
in europäischen gewässern manövriert auf
widerstände traf sie nicht haben sie im
mitte gemeinsam mit russischen marine
schon im baltikum in ostia operieren
sehen im mittelmeer operiert sie da ist
etwas woran man sich gewöhnen muss aber
umso mehr ist es ein grund für europa
weltweit eben auch für die eigenen werte
einzustehen und selber flagge zu zeigen
die fregatte bayern die gegen china
flagge zeigen soll hat in china einen
freundschaftsbesuch angemeldet es ist
eine widersprüchliche eine sehr
bundesdeutsche mission 1 macht weiter
mit wirtschaften da gibt es etwas
erfreuliches zu vermelden
die geschäfte im deutschen einzelhandel
haben im juni ein deutliches umsatzplus
verzeichnet sowohl gegenüber dem
vormonat mai als auch im vergleich zum
juli letzten jahres das gab das
statistische bundesamt bekannt stephanie
beckert in welchen bereichen haben denn
die verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
besonders viel eingekauft wo gab sind
die größten pluszeichen ja ziemlich
exakt mit den lockerungen der krone
beschränkungen ging es im juni im
stationären einzelhandel steil aufwärts
während der onlinehandel jahr
überraschenderweise sogar leicht
rückläufig war
kunden setzen offenbar auf das erlebnis
innenstadt und holten vieles nach vor
allem bekleidung schuhe und lederwaren
in geschäften gefragt sage und schreibe
gut 70 prozent mehr verkäufe gegenüber
dem mai auch einrichtungsgegenstände und
haushaltsgeräte legten um gut 18 prozent
zu sogar kaufhäuser wirkten wieder als
magnete in den stadtzentren und machten
über 30 prozent mehr umsatz
mancherorts ist bereits von einer
wiederbelebung der innenstädte die rede
geschlossene geschäfte kinos und
restaurants all das
in den privaten haushalten einen konsum
stau und eine beispiellose sparquote
herbeigeführt deshalb gehen ökonomen
auch deshalb davon aus dass der
privatkonsum europas größte
volkswirtschaft in den kommenden monaten
anschieben wird gut drei millionen
branche mitarbeiter dürften nach
anderthalbjähriger durststrecke aufatmen
doch für viele einzelhändler ist die
krise längst nicht vorbei der
handelsverband deutschland sieht
weiterhin die existenz von 50.000
geschäften gefährdet die lage im
einzelhandel sie bleibt fragil
stephanie beckert vielen dank beim
personalausweis gibt es neuerungen ab
heute gilt wer einen beantragt bekommt
ihn im neuen design und mitarbeitern
sicherheitsstandards entsprechend eine
angleichung innerhalb der eu
verpflichtend ist jetzt auch die abgabe
von fingerabdrücken bei der beantragung
die bislang ausgestellten
personalausweise bleiben aber gültig bis
zum aufgedruckten ablaufdatum
ein vorzeitiger umtausch wegen der
neuerungen ist laut
bundesinnenministerium nicht notwendig
ob sich die menschen in 150 oder mehr
jahren fasziniert ansehen und anhören
werden was wir so alles produzierten an
bildern videos und audio aufnahmen man
weiß es nicht
umgekehrt ist die faszination hingegen
groß was vielleicht auch daran liegt
dass im neunzehnten jahrhundert
tonaufnahmen noch etwas so neues und
revolutionäres waren dass es eben auch
nicht so viele davon gibt sich eine
verrauschte gesangs aufnahme von 1860
anzuhören hat auf jeden fall seinen
besonderen reiz für liebhaber der
klassischen musik gibt es noch eine
andere variante das sogenannte
reproduktions klavier eine art musik
automat der anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts große begeisterung auslöste
berühmte komponisten spielten ihre
eigenen stücke damit ein
und das wiederum ist heute dank
digitaler technik eine
musikwissenschaftliche foto sven glas
nimmt uns mit zu einer zeitreise am
klavier
ihr spielt sergej rachmaninow einer der
begehrtesten klaviervirtuosen seinerzeit
längst verstorben was er vor rund 100
jahren eingespielt hat wird an diesen
modernen flügel an der musikhochschule
in freiburg jetzt neu erlebbar
die tasten angetrieben von zisch kleinen
elektromotoren
die distanz fällt weg die man sonst über
das medium des anhören die
nebengeräusche die dinge die sonst dazu
kommen erlebt sondern man ist direkt
dabei
das ist rachmaninows interpretation
seines eigenen werkes
[Musik]
genauso bei alexander skrjabin auch ein
vertreter der berühmten russischen
schule
[Musik]
auch er hat vor rund 100 jahren an einem
speziellen klavier der freiburger firma
welte seine werke aufgezeichnet auf
solchen papierrollen verewigt
dieses sogenannte reproduktions klavier
damals eine weltsensation
die rolle wird mit saugt luft abgetastet
kommt ein loch kann luft durchströmen
die über ventile im inneren den
tastenanschlag auslöst
[Musik]
es war das erste mal dass sozusagen auch
auf dem gleichen instrumenten art
wiedergegeben worden ist das heißt man
hat auf einem klavier oder einem flügel
eingespielt und konnte das spiel auf
einem flügel wiedergeben und pianisten
haben teilweise gesagt das ist das erste
mal dass ich mich überhaupt selber
gehört habe auf dem papier ryanair fast
jeder pedal einsatz jeder tastenanschlag
dessen dynamik ziemlich exakt sind sie
heute überzeugt
einige der rollen haben sie inzwischen
aufwendig digitalisiert für moderne
reproduktions klaviere
ich kenne die rolle in bern ich bekomme
erst das foto dann werden daraus die
rohdaten per software erzeugt die
schicke ich nach australien und nach
sydney und zurück bekomme ich dann eine
datei die auch die dynamik moniert
enthält die ich dann auf dem display
abspielen der disc flügel sozusagen
nachfahre des welte klaviers den
studierenden ermöglichen diese
technologie und die digitalisierung
neben längst verstorbenen pianisten auf
der klavierbank zu setzen teile deren
spiels auszuschalten und so mit ihnen
gemeinsam zu musizieren
ganz direkter zugang habe ich jetzt das
gewinnen das ist das faszinierende weil
wir haben sehr viel respekt vor text
notentext aber jetzt sehe ich gerade wie
improvisatorisch er umgeht mit seinem
text und es gibt mir auch die freiheit
und die inspiration auch selber sachen
auszuprobieren
der pool an aufnahmen ist derweil längst
nicht erschöpft mehr als 4000
papierrollen berühmter pianisten sind
bei welte weltweit einst entstanden
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts im
für viele goldenen zeitalter des
klavierspiels
[Musik]
das war es von uns gleich geht es mit
dem montagskino weiter und um 23.50
gibt's dann unser heute schon ein update
mit wulf schmiese und wir sagen auf
wiedersehen bis morgen wenn sie mir
[Musik]
eine ampel und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter solange dieser umfangreiche tief
komplex über mitteleuropa festhängt
einmal vom atlantik über nord afrika bis
in den osten europas
so lange werden auch weitere tiefs
entlang ziehen und uns unwetter bringen
das nächste liegt schon über den
britischen inseln und überquert uns
morgen im tagesverlauf ja und auf der
vorderseite dieses komplexes wird warme
bis heiße luft in richtung griechenland
und türkei transportiert und die
temperaturen hier bis 45 grad in
griechenland diese werte werden im laufe
der woche auch noch in der türkei
erreicht und von der klimakrise heraus
gesehen werden diese hitzewellen länger
und auch teilweise intensiver und kommen
häufiger vor
schauen wir auf die nacht da kommen der
zweiten nachthälfte von westen her regen
wolken auf die gehören zu diesem tiefe
ansonsten ist es trocken im südosten
sogar stern klar mit temperaturen von
neun grad im nordwesten deutschlands und
im süden 13 grad an der ostsee und
morgen vor allem in der nordhälfte
längere zeit sonnige abschnitte
ansonsten aber teils kräftige gewitter
mit starkregen und hagel und sturmböen
am ehesten trocken bleibt es noch im
südosten aber dann später auch dort die
gewitter temperaturen erreichen
höchstwerte von 23 grad im osten und 17
im westen deutschlands
am mittwoch dann weitere schauer in der
südhälfte vor allem bis 23 grad und am
donnerstag gesellen sich auch wieder
gewitter dazu ein schöner amt